mein name ist luca meine lieben freunde
ich liebe tipptopp wirklich extrem kratz
die einzige sache die mich so ein
bisschen stört an der app sind
allerdings die live streams
die finnischen sich gut allerdings sind
ja echt teilweise komische leute dabei
von daher hab ich mir heute ein beispiel
an laser beam genommen und will einige
tik tok stream abholen
ich habe mir für 55 euro tik tok calls
gekauft und wir schauen jetzt mal rein
was wir in live streams damit zu
anstellen können keine ahnung was seine
mission ist aber anscheinend hat er
einfach deutsche schlager wenn du
bessere musik an was du nette ich dir
fünf euro ok weltkrieg seien keine filme
täglich ab 11 30 wir lernen zusammen wir
machen pause und zwei minuten 15 also er
will anscheinend mit seinen zuschauern
hier lernen ich weiß nicht ob da
überhaupt kommentare liest liest du die
commons hier habe ich jetzt einfach mal
kommentiert die sache sei dass der check
dass ich hier bin er halt aber nicht
dass jetzt auch nicht hier so ganz
geklappt ich bin mir überlegt es ist
eine menge geld ich weiß aber er
versteht nicht was die kauf wenn du dir
luca auf die stirn schreibst du ich die
zehn euro zu deiner jacke dazu was mache
ich hier
ich halte meine movies tabelle videos
das ist ein jahr her
sie sagt da war sie noch voll kleid das
ist ein jahr her okay du kriegst fünf
euro wenn du ganz laut luca - shop.de
schrei wenn du ganz so lukas punkt ist
ich kann nicht ich kann es ich hab
nachbarn sg talle auf lukas shop.de
du solltest schreien die welt sollte
höre nicht hier die wie viele leute
gucken denn zu 216 leute okay dass er
dafür kriegst auf jeden fall eine
kleinigkeit komme ich bin eine
sonnenbrille
[Musik]
die hose dazu na und mein fall so dafür
dass er ein streber brille aufhatte dann
hätte ich ihn jetzt direkte brille
umzuziehen dahinter darüber muss jetzt
noch ein schreckliches anderes outfit ja
ich könnte da nur website empfiehlt
[Musik]
nicht
hey hallo julia hat sich rechte
verbindung ich net do 10 euro wenn er
jetzt auf kommando obst nicht machen wir
nicht aber zehn euro wenn du lebst
lieber kein sky fiber laser luca wurde
vom moderator stunde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fünf euro wenn du oft kommando
substituierte jetzt einfach mal so eine
kleine schokolade die kost eine münze
das ist das ist nicht so jetzt habe ich
die aufmerksamkeit
du kriegst fünf euro wenn du lebst
landsmann in der stadt man jetzt hängt
ihr internet gut kommen wir gehen weiter
zum nächsten stream
okay sie schminkt sich gerade auf die
geben mir fünf euro wenn sie jetzt
aufhört sich zu schminken ich bin
gespannt ob sie darauf eingehen wird
die nachricht kam nach mir wenig moniert
die muss ich jedem erst geldspenden dass
sie einen überhaupt vorlesen kommen du
kriegst du jetzt erstmal in mühlacker
kriegt sich denner geht auf mich
zurückziehen
warum woher ich darf mich allein schafft
ich gern wenn du jetzt auf kommando
obsternte ich dir zehn euro auf meinen
nacken
ich habe dich vor jetzt habe ich kenn
dich du bist auch manchmal lustig
brüssel für eine euro schwäche wie auf
einem jahrmarkt wenn es auf kommando
obst aber du kannst mir auch so gehen
beim abschuss zehn euro wenn du die eine
auf die keb haus will keiner hier mein
geld arbeiten 550 euro draufgepackt 20
euro wenn du dir eine beere in die nase
steckt das kann doch nicht sein dass
keiner ihr irgendwie was einfach trocken
oder eine beere in die nase was ist wo
ich es probiert war quatsch
ja meine hingegen entspricht also kennen
die mich mal aufklären ist lesbisch nein
steffi jungs ich habe nichts gegen
lesben oder als ob es dieser lukas
verarscht mich nicht machen wir nicht
diese wäre nicht jeden morgen in die
nase in die nase 20 euro nein doch ich
habe es auf video ja sogar musste kotzen
oder was 20 euro wenn du dir eine beere
in die nase steckt
ich kann eigentlich alle grüßen von mir
eine beere kurz in die nase nicht deine
hände vor den mund er ist immer noch
natürlich ist wirklich reinschieben
damit ich jetzt youtube-videos und es
ist so oder so drin
aber ob du 20 uhr über haben euch so
nicht am ende steht mir das jetzt
komisch com
das passt einfach nicht hast nicht mehr
rein muss aufziehen wird die gase haben
die leider habe ich ihr den kleinen
bären
sie hat eine kleinere biel will so eine
brombeere da kommen jetzt aber 120 tagen
bat einen moment ich machtlos
ob er in die nase meiner mutter okay da
wirklich für 25 euro ich denke kommen
steckt ja immer die bären die nase ich
bin klar
ich steck dir wirklich dass wir gerade
angefangen luca ich muss ich leider
enttäuschen
meine mutter ist spaß
die hat mich gar nicht ob ich mit der
ich glaube das nicht machen
du musst ein bisschen so aufziehen und
danach safety nicht kommt jetzt
mach einfach ich natürlich passt das
einfach entschieden ist
ich hab jetzt ja aber auch 20 euro ich
hätte das nicht machen sollen
das brennt komme ich hier nochmal was
ich geb dir nochmal so ein konzert typen
hier seine gitarre einfach schließlich
gebe die einfach aus prinzip 2008 hat
sich die sieht das nicht weil die sich
neben beim schminken ist das ist klar
[Musik]
luca guck mal ich glaube du denkst ich
bin 16 oder fünfzehn oder so und gefragt
warum kommst aus laser luke adam strausz
gewendet durfte freut sich herr
jägermeister hut ein problem gehabt viel
schwarz wie wir hoffen doch der stelle
würde ich den heutigen tag der folge
allerdings beendete lieben freundes
sorry dass es heute kein normaler tik
tok tuesday war in dem sinne dass ich
euch die lustigsten tipp der woche
gezeigt haben sondern einfach mal ein
paar streamer geträumt habe ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wenn etwas getan hat
las gerne daumen runter video der
abonniert main kanal und wir sehen uns
morgen